[Music]
we know that mitochondria may indeed be
endosymbiosis in the sense that millions
of years ago these tiny bacteria were
engulfed by larger cells and ultimately
evolved to be codependent with ourselves
we provide them with foodstuffs and
protection from predation and in turn
they provide us with the majority of the
ATP energy currency that our cells need
to do work well you may not realize
however is that each mitochondrion has
its own DNA its own genome so what that
means is that while we are accustomed to
thinking of ourselves and their genomes
in terms of what exists in the nucleus
all of the genes that we think of as the
ones we inherit from our mother and from
our father we cannot forget that the
mitochondria in every single cell also
carry their own DNA genomes now where
did those DNA genomes come from well
another interesting fact is that we only
get mitochondria from our mothers the
mitochondria come with the egg while the
sperm that we got from our fathers in
terms of fertilization do not contribute
any mitochondria to what will ultimately
develop in embryogenesis into us into an
adult human being so this is of course a
debt that we owe our mothers they are
the source of our mitochondria but then
if you want to think about what we
inherit and are there possible mutations
that we might inherit we can't just
think about what we inherit in terms of
the nuclear genomes what we hear it from
our Father and from our mother we also
must think about what mitochondria we
inherited from our mothers it was fairly
recently when we discovered that there
are a number of human diseases usually
metabolic diseases that are tied to the
inheritance of mutations in the
mitochondrial genome many of these
diseases as you might expect are related
to lower than normal
levels of ATP or defects for example in
the electron transport chain defects
that really affect if you will the
energy metabolism that we all need so
crucially for all of nice processes so
the question is where did these defects
come from in mitochondria and how can we
understand the process of inheritance
that occurs let's begin by thinking
about my cells mitochondria and what the
makeup of those mitochondria might look
like so if we have a cell from our
bodies we have a nucleus and then we may
have multiple mitochondria in a cell
usually we'll have anywhere from ten to
twenty nine Condry now when we think
about this we generally think of the
nuclei or a single nucleus in a single
cell as having a particular genome but
what we don't usually think about is
that the mitochondria in a cell are in
fact a population they are not all the
same and in particular if you think
about their genomes their genomes may
not be all the same so here we have
shown a number of mitochondria and we're
distinguishing their genomes by color so
we have let's say four mitochondria that
we are designated as having one
particular genome in purple we have two
in pink and we have three in orange now
let's suppose that there's a defect in
the mitochondrial genomes and the defect
is associated with these two
mitochondria that are pink what this
means is that the defects are associated
with two mitochondria but we have
another four in fact seven mitochondria
that are otherwise perfectly healthy and
so when it comes to the state of that
cell
whether or not there's a negative impact
of those mutations will depend on how
many mitochondria are defective
mitochondrial diseases are really quite
devastating if you think about it it's
not really surprising because given the
low that mitochondria play in providing
the majority of ATP that we need any
disease that disrupts their ability to
produce ATP to manufacture ATP can have
significant metabolic impacts so
mitochondrial disease often involves for
example muscle weakness and wasting
because muscles use a significant amount
of ATP
it also can involve cognitive defects
sort of degeneration of the brain
because on what as one would expect
neurons and nerve cells in the brain
also utilize an enormous amount of ATP
how common our mitochondria disease is
they're really one of the more common
kinds of genetic diseases for example in
the United States where you will see a
frequency of roughly one in five to ten
thousand births might have some kind of
mitochondrial disease because of the
severity or the possible severity of
mitochondrial disease you also
frequently see lethality by h2 so that
quite often if there's a severe
expression of a mitochondrial disease
you might have a stillborn kind of
situation or you may also have a case
where the child dies by age two so
clearly this is a very severe kind of
disease but it also reveals a remarkably
different kind of inheritance than
anything we've seen before
you
[Music]